hello everyone i'm dana perino along
with emmalin camp ano juan williams
Jesse Watters and Greg Gutfeld is 5
o'clock in New York City this is the 5
[Music]
the battle for 2020 heating up now that
Joe Biden has officially entered the
race President Trump going on the attack
against the former vice president and
Democratic frontrunner he's not the
brightest light bulb in the group I've
known him for a while and he's a pretty
sleepy guy he's not going to be able to
deal with President Xi I will tell you
that's a different level of energy and
frankly intelligence I think we beat him
easily
I'm so young I can't believe it I'm the
youngest person I am a young vibrant man
I look at Joe I don't know about him I
don't know why didn't returning fire at
the president today on the view if he
looks young and vibrant compared to me I
should probably go home the best way to
judge me is to watch see if I have the
energy and the capacity and I mean it's
it it's just you know show me business
you know you aren't sleeping Joe that's
the first time I've ever been referenced
that way by anyone else
Biden also asked about controversies
that could hurt him in the primaries
including allegations of violating
personal space and his treatment of
Anita Hill during the Clarence Thomas
confirmation hearings are you sorry for
what you did are you prepared to
apologize to those women I'm really
sorry if they what I did in talking to
them trying to console that in fact they
took it a different way so I'm very your
space I mean I I I'm sorry this happened
if you reached out to Anita Hill and you
personally expressed some regret to her
about the way you behaved I guess back
in 1991 I'm sorry the way she got
treated the in terms of I never heard
say it if you go back and look what I
said and didn't say I I don't think I
treated her badly Jesse the president's
not wasting any time he's not gonna wait
for the Democrats to figure out their
primary before he starts shooting back
he's just gonna go for it right away
yeah the sleepy thing definitely sticks
I didn't realize how sleepy he was until
he answered questions about him being
sleepy I almost drooled to hear on the
set the there's gonna be an issue for
Joe
and I don't think he's as the
temperament or the talent to handle this
he's not used to being the front-runner
and he's not used to being attacked from
the left and he's also not used to tough
questions from the media and when he is
a privileged white straight Christian
male running in this primary there's
gonna be a moment in this primary either
at a debate or at on the trail when he's
gonna get attacked and he's gonna snap
and he's gonna lose it a little bit
because he's frustrated he doesn't have
to handle himself and those are the
gonna be the defining moments when
people attack him identity politics from
the left the other problem he has his
media Barack Obama had a hundred percent
media support Biden's not going to have
that and you've seen now the I think The
Daily Beast which is a traditional
partisan attack rag for Democrats they
have a whole story out today saying this
was a bumbling and stumbling interview
on the left now if he's going to survive
this primary he needs a he needs to
consolidate media support because right
now his opponents are dumping all the
oppo at the traditional media places
like The Washington Post and The Times
these online publications they don't
like him anyway because he's you know to
moderate in their view and then cable
news I believe everybody knows on cable
that Joe Biden is an overrated candidate
and they're gonna build them up and then
they're gonna tear them down and you
just watch there was a Howard Dean
remember Howard Dean is green Greg let
me play this for you and have you just
talked about what Jesse said and also
Howard Dean's point how much this this
party's being taken over by 35 year olds
the people who won the races are 35
years old and they're mostly centrist
they're not particularly liberals a aoc
gets all the press or not who I'm a big
fan of receded sleeve Oh Marilla on gets
all they get all the press there's 37
people that come from Orange County
Texas Oklahoma Kansas that's where your
tats where we picked up the seeds
I don't know what he was talking about
there I was going one way and then he
went another way I thought it was like
he was mad that they were young but then
they're not raised them then he praised
them and I just realized each gram of my
brain
the problem with Joe Biden is that he's
been around for a long long time and
there's no defining positive achievement
that he can point to he's like that
character on a TV show that's there all
the time let's say Gunther on friends
the barista he's in every single episode
but there's no impact there doesn't have
to he is the Gunther a candidate he's
like your tonsils you know they're there
to cool it they're there but if they're
not there you're not gonna miss your
tonsils Dana I think this is a battle
between physical evidence and
psychological effect Trump offers the
physical evidence of achievement in his
first term jobs a great economy GDP you
got a stronger military and foreign
policy looks pretty good
Biden offers the psychological strategy
Trump makes you feel bad he's a bad guy
he makes you feel get that but you the
problem is that it won't work because
you don't have to like Trump to vote for
him you don't we've gone past the idea
of personality and that stuff we know
now looking at the practical the
practical elements of an administration
and it's really an awesome time in
history to have a president who likes to
participate like America's heckler yeah
I just sit there and just like this is
gonna go on for two years Trump is going
to be America's heckler and it's gonna
be kind of fun it'll be kind of fun I'm
let me have you listen to another piece
to what Gregg was just saying this is
Joe Biden about Americans coming back
yes America is coming back like we used
to be ethical straight tell him the
truth
moving it away is that the rationale for
his presidency that he's gonna bring us
back to whatever but all the things that
he just said is that the goal oh yeah I
mean that's why you saw yesterday the
slogan for the rollout was the soul of
America that he wants to get us back
away from what George Conway has now
called do
Donald right which is a trending Twitter
thing he's going to bring us back to
sanity to civility make it straight on
your honest kinds of conversations not
racial division not picking on people
not bullying people you know what I
think is you're missing here the big
news of the day to me is Donna Joe Biden
raising six point three I was million
dollars and twenty four hours which way
exceeds my expectations I didn't think
he was capable of it because a lot of
this came from the small donors who have
few Bernie Sanders and it I had the
impression that you know Joe Biden has
never been a great fundraiser would be
unable to go at it in this way he did
Donald Trump going at him as a sleepy or
tired or dumb how ridiculous I mean
first of all it's just not true he's a
DJ in a second he's an intelligent man I
think most Americans notice and when you
see him on the view today oh my gosh
when he's talking about his son Beau and
when he starts to cry in front of a
mostly female audience that's the views
audience he comes across as genuine as
authentic as connecting with women in a
way Donald Trump couldn't dream on what
evidence do you have the Joe Biden is
super intelligent I know Joe Biden I
dealt with him Joe Biden was in the
Senate went back to when he was in the
Senate excuse me
six times six times sent to the Senate
by the citizens of Delaware he was not
only the guy who was there and head of
judiciary for not only Clarence Thomas
but for many others but remember there's
a lifelong policy he was great with
Anita Hill he's a very good highly
respected senator by people on both
sides of the aisle I know in your a
partisan world that doesn't make sense
he is in fact one of the most esteemed
senators of his time and vice president
the United States Emily and I'm gonna
ask you you could answer anything you
want but I was gonna bring up the fact
that the other two people that initially
came out a well a little bit of a
broadside against a Biden was Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren Bernie
Sanders attacking him for having the big
high-rolling fundraiser last night in
Philadelphia and Warren was kind of an
arcane issue a credit
her tissue back in 2005 but she's never
really liked him it makes sense to me
that they came out swinging right away
because they are the ones that have the
most to lose right if they if anyone
they would lose their supporters to
Biden and same with Mayor Pete as well
who also had something to say and
obviously as the in tax increase and his
approval rating will go down I feel like
in terms of the president's attacks on
him to and to speak to your point to
speak to everybody's point okay it makes
me think of hump is like a shark in the
water and regardless of how much money
Biden raises he is similar to a jet in
that he raised a ton of money to and
ultimately it didn't matter and Trump
smells that limp lame geriatric sealed
going after him just like Jeb because
it's gonna be easy to pick off and he
would love to run against him in 2020
but it's easy to pick off now and to
speak to your point about his history he
is thirty years of nothing and I think
for the argument of name recognition
there's also a lot of name fatigue and
you can see in the media coverage what
he talked about The Daily Beast all the
memes that came out immediately there's
some reports that oh the media was
glowing reports of him and all of a
sudden the view viewers loved him I
thought his public display of emotion
was manufactured and ridiculous
so I am on that other flip side where
I'm like this entire thing is totally
laughable he'll be picked on know what I
thought though I think that it worked
for him on the view just like yesterday
with the rollout the whole business
about Charlottesville I know there are a
lot of people who said hey why did he
focus so heavily on Charlottesville but
guess what what did you see from Donald
Trump today he's back on his heels
having to explain what he said about
Charlottesville defending robert e lee a
traitor a man who led to the deaths of
American troops Wow Biden quoted Thomas
Jefferson a slaveholder so there you go
have to do it you just contradicted
yourself he brought up robert e lee and
biden brought up thomas jefferson
o'reilly robert e lee was a traitor to
the United States yes and every Thomas
Jefferson was the slave hold yeah but
that's different he does not pointing
out I'm pointing out that you're
overlooking some flaws right I think he
was talking about military campaigning